welcome back to cbs mornings nasa is
counting down to the first flight test
for its new moon program the unpiloted
mission called artemis one is due to
liftoff monday morning nasa is counting
on the rocket to bring astronauts to the
moon for the first time in half a
century here it is on the launch pad at
florida's kennedy space center ready to
go mark straussman is there mark good
morning this is a really big deal
it's all big here janie good morning to
you both this rocket and this moment for
nasa even from a distance so what you
see standing on the pad behind me looks
imposing the most powerful rocket nasa
has ever built and we're just days away
now from seeing whether it works
it's a great site seeing that artemis
vehicle on the pad
charlie blackwell thompson the artemis
one launch director leads a team of 100
here inside the kennedy space center's
firing room ntd launch director it's up
to her to give the go to launch the most
powerful rocket nasa has ever built it
does bring an entirely new capability
it's going to return our nation to the
moon and it is going to pave the way for
our next steps in exploration as we
prepare to go someplace like mars
this rocket is a monster
322 feet tall weighing almost 6 million
pounds when fully fueled for nasa the
stakes are just as massive artemis one
needs to work
8.8 million pounds of thrust will lift
the space launch system rocket skyward
on top orion a next generation crew
capsule
orion will fly on a 42-day mission into
a distant lunar orbit reaching roughly
40 thousand miles beyond the moon the
farthest point ever for a vehicle that
can carry humans
but on this flight the only passengers
will be mannequins outfitted with
sensors collecting data we need to put
the rocket on the pad with the capsule
on top and send it to the moon make sure
it comes back safely you have to test
all of those things before we put humans
in those seats and ask them to go do
something that's never been done before
watching closely astronaut kayla barron
the next artemis mission artemis ii set
for 2024 will have a crew for a test
flight around the moon and back a lot of
people ask why would we go back to the
moon we want to travel to mars and mars
is really really far from planet earth
and the first human crew to go do that
might be testing equipment that we've
never had the opportunity to test before
and the perfect place to practice that
is the lunar surface that's one small
step for man
the apollo missions landed near the
moon's equator artemis will aim for its
south pole where dark craters may hold
ice that can be converted to rocket fuel
air and water nasa has announced 13
potential touchdown targets for artemis
iii the first lunar landing mission
later this decade using a spacex lander
long-term plans call for a mini space
station in lunar orbit we are ready to
proceed into our pretest briefing but
first the most complex rocket in history
must prove itself for nasa's artemis
generation to get its moonshot moment i
think we have done all of the things
that you can do to be ready and i find
myself many mornings when i come out to
go to work and the moon is up in the sky
i will look up
and i'll think we're coming back
and we're coming back soon
and another measure of this moment come
monday morning more than 100 000 people
are expected to line the beaches and
causeways hoping for a glimpse of the
liftoff
jamie
it makes sense it's so fun to watch mark
thank you
the launch of artemis one is scheduled
for monday morning cbs news will bring
it to you in a special report i'm
looking forward to that i'll be watching
yeah i mean it's just crazy that like
just think about how far away the moon
and then also mars is when they're gonna
go 40 000 miles past the moon and
they're still just out there in
nothingness it's like you're on the
highway you saw a sign that was like
last stop for gas in 40 000 miles you're
like here we go that's a long way
i love the fact that
they have to put mannequins in those
seats it puts things in perspective yeah
well yeah because it's never been done
well we did go to the moon before yeah
some people i'm talking about how far
they have now though yeah they're going
further than ever and apollo was
designed to end its mission on the moon
this artemis is is starting its true
mission with this trip
so it's it's a whole new era plus we all
get to play walter cronkite if it
happens we can sit here on set and take
our glasses off and express the wonder
of generations exactly